we have a david pakman show subreddit at
david pakman.com slash read it nearly
10,000 of our viewers and listeners
subscribed and participating daily in
political discussion a couple of
interesting threads i spotted on the
subreddit this morning that i wanted to
call to your attention the first of
which is david can't admit he was wrong
that's a problem that's leonardo McClure
doe who I'm sure is using some kind of
pen name
listen I've already addressed this and I
in fact an entire livestream about it
yesterday mostly focused around this
issue there's video of me from a year
ago saying I do not believe I think the
chances of Trump having personally
actively colluded with Putin in a
deliberate way are almost zero that's a
quote that's a quote from a video a year
ago so for everybody's saying I was
wrong about something related to Trump
Russia or that I need to apologize I
need you to tell me exactly what and I
need you to provide citations because
it's been very very frustrating when
there are demands around something so
vague and amorphous and I think that
anyone who seriously looks at the data
meaning the videos will find that so far
I have been spot on when it comes to the
Russia investigation which is we can all
see plain as day what it is that took
place but if you are waiting around for
Trump to be charged with anything
related to collusion don't hold your
breath because it simply was was never
going to happen because that's simply
not how things work and on the
obstruction piece I think we've already
delved into it so I'm ready to provide
any apologies necessary on the basis of
you actually being able to cite
something that I need to apologize for
also from the David Pakman show
subreddit did the majority report rip
off Smallville this is so funny so
there's been a sort of fake controversy
over the last couple of weeks that our
new set looks suspiciously like sam
cedars set but a number of people have
pointed out that there are episodes of
Smallville that have a sort of tiled
background that looks a lot like sam
cedars set and of course
pre-dated is Smallville like the
Smallville to Superman prequel type of
thing like I don't even know what show
that is bad I don't know if it's a
prequel I guess it must be because I
think the main character is a teenage
Superman but I didn't watch it myself so
I can't vouch for sure yeah I mean I'm
going by the evidence that's been
presented which is that Smallville had
Sam set long before he had it so anyway
I don't know if we'll ultimately have a
resolution here I've retained Mark
Geragos to represent me in the
intellectual property lawsuit being
brought by one of Sam's listeners and I
will have more news for you about the
litigation very very soon
but seriously join the subreddit at
david pakman.com slash our IDI di t we
all know and have talked about how
mentally exhausting it has become to
keep up with the news lately because of
everything that's been going on over the
last few years which is why I'm so happy
to tell you about one of today's
sponsors simple habit and it's an app
that gives you instant access to
thousands of really good five-minute
guided meditations and I encourage you
to try it for free by going to simple
habit dot-com slash Pakman each
meditation on simple habit was designed
for a specific purpose like waking up
falling asleep dealing with stress
getting focused for work that you have
to do
I've really enjoyed integrating simple
habit into my day especially because
they just make it so easy
each meditation is just five minutes
long different meditations are catered
for whatever you're doing whether you're
driving to work or you're on your lunch
break or you're winding down for the day
we're constantly seeing new research
about how many benefits there are to
meditation and simple habit is the
perfect way for beginners to get started
with meditation but it's also just as
useful for people who already meditate
and want a library of guided meditations
right at their fingertips the app also
just won the 2018 Google Play award for
best well-being app I think almost
anyone could hugely benefit from an app
like this you can try it
for free for a week by going to simple
habit dot-com / Pakman I've put a link
underneath this video